the reason we actually picked the name
at the start is because there was a guy
who did like he has this like really
grandiose voice with him like one
direction we were like that sounds good
that guy will say that nice and that was
where we picked the man pay from and now
we're everywhere and not together
anymore and now we're many directions
but I don't think it sounds quite as
good what's up GQ I'm Liam Payne and
these are my essentials I am Number One
I would go for having a good Bluetooth
speaker because I feel like when I get
up in the morning I need music I mean I
don't get up straight away and put big E
on in the morning that's not really what
I do but I know I love hip-hop music and
there's some really great tunes out
there at the moment
I don't know actually know where the
hell this one came from why did we get
this speaker when you go to like these
different award shows if you get like
goodie bags and there's always a
Bluetooth speaker in the bag sound like
a great this bluetooth speakers
everywhere it's fantastic so if we have
a lose one we'll have to just make sure
we go to some sort of fancy box we
schedule a fancy pie someone so this is
my spray so you smell nice I think is
important that you always smile Isis is
part of human nature and you should
always take care of ourselves this is my
my girlfriend's favorite smell on me
which I went to a thing where I had like
an array of of different smells but she
was like um not wearing the same one as
you word for it she likes me to smell
the same size to make sure obvious my
design laws I get a funny look I just
like having a lot of snow around with me
because I mean I meet a lot of people
everyday any of them having a tough day
at least they can't smell the real me up
in my mouth there it tastes as good as
it smells
I'd say that
[Music]
this is like my most recent little
passion that I have this is actually my
drawing but where I've started sketching
up but I recently got really into I
found out I was alright it so I thought
I might make a little bit the go doing
things by just I've only really just
started so I've done one drawing of this
build and I did so far this is actually
all of my pens at least like a lot of
travel pencil kit which I found out that
I've lost my pencil sharpener and which
in Spanish is on second Bumpus anybody
who's listening and yes oh that's gone
missing so enough to have it all doesn't
round for that that is also essential
you want to draw you gotta have a sharp
pencil but when I'm not drawing I use
the camera and I go and I take pictures
of things that I want to draw I was
watching David Hockney the other day on
a documentary that he didn't he goes out
to like a woods and you look at the
woods and then he'll go back home and I
go right what do I remember the most no
stark like well there was that tree over
there now actually remember what was
left the tree oh yeah there was that
road bit there then he just draws it
from memory but I'm Way too insane to do
any enough planes or you know when I'm
traveling and I've got time in a hotel
draw the view out the window or
something different so yeah I like
sketching so that's another little hobby
that I have next
[Music]
always have a nice pair of trainers
because they finish off the only outfit
really in English which is trainers
because apparently people sneak around
in the more in America and people
training them in the UK so these are the
nice looking pair of New Balance that I
think took the other day which are super
cool and then I have these desk sorry I
did one for my feet on your left foot I
thought it I used to hate wearing color
when I was young I remember my first
meeting with a stylist and I didn't know
what the hell to do because it's like I
don't know much about clothes know where
what he's around and that's what I kind
of did and then I went for a real point
of wearing loads of colors and then now
I've kind of settled out to these kind
of nudes and and I don't know these
little flashes of color which is quite
nice the men would but yeah I don't know
I think you just get more comfortable
wearing what you're wearing as time goes
by and as you know you've aged with
fashion someone who looks like this is
actually a vocal steamer called dr.
Nelson's improved inhaler and I've
smashed a bunch of these so now we have
loads when you wake up in the morning
you first talking like oh I like it you
have to get rid of that as quick as
possible when you're singing I mean I
did a show the other day for Good
Morning America and I was up at 3:00 in
the morning
exercising my voice to sing that like
six which I didn't know when I got into
doing this actually it was gonna be like
really really early morning so you think
7 o'clock was early for school it works
by you put hot boiling water into about
here you put it in too high then you
suck in boiling water which is out many
times and you just gotta inhale the
steam and then blow back out and it just
kind of clears everything up and you
feel like by the end of it I can't wait
to show my peanut bring on the pig
energy while we're here we've dived into
thief at this point it is for shaving
use very well named
cordless just to keep the beard trim
because sometimes I look like I don't
even know what with the beard and it
really adds to your face like I feel
like I lose weight when I shaved my face
which also adds to this bit which is gym
gear
you always have good gym gear with you
we started doing yoga recently which is
quite funny in the mornings which we
haven't done for a full bottle I think
we laughed more than we were supposed to
it the yoga but I think they added there
should be a form of laughing yoga where
you go in and there's like someone who
tells jokes
whilst you do certain poses and when you
laugh it adds to your ab work you like
laughing it hurts and then you like are
ready all those opposed no it's fun like
that it should be a thing like we have
hot yoga
Liam's laughing yoga laugh and yoga
there comes always a good one to look
out for workout gear he really stars out
with the little towel addition and the
backwards hat you seem like rolling
through LA when he's been to the gym
like it's called bike I was obviously
really bad impression of David Beckham
but there you go
so what we have here is gym gear hair
wax always need a bit hair I'm actually
growing my hair out at the moment so the
wax changes as you go really I guess
when it's like long you need a more
slick Huestis a bit more harder cuz I've
got short hair at the moment but I'm
going for that awkward grow out stage
it's tough place to be let me show you
your head remember you do grow it back
it's you have to go through that awkward
stage of like wait longer parts of its
not supposed to be short on other parts
where you don't want it to be happens to
me all the time hair wax definitely an
essential one of my essentials is camera
Marty so when you finish I come off the
stage you get this little thing where
the adrenaline like kind of comes out of
your body as you as you settle back into
normal life and you have to drink some
of this to sleep because you're like way
too excited about life now she has a
thing in the tea that makes you the
battle against like anxiety which is
quite nice it's good too and also
another one for vocals ginger shots it's
also really healthy for you but it's
good for getting your once again throw
ready to sing in the morning if you've
got an early show or you feeling
something cold remember the weather
tea ginger essentials major essential
mass sports you need them if you're
gonna go places they won't let you win
doesn't matter who you are where you
come from and they always have really
awkward pictures in them but I can't
show you that there's a passport and
then obviously when you've used your
passport and you've gotten on your look
at journeys places Sony's you know keep
your eyes sealed from the Sun and trying
look cool as cool as you can I'm
terrible for not traveling with cases
for sunglasses I get a lot of battered
pairs of sunglasses as well to get like
satin and it's always all companies
sipping your sunglasses in it one of the
worst things nice car so don't sell any
sunglasses travel with a case I can
actually see these have been sat on it
the more I talk about it and I need to
now bend the nose bits back in place I'm
good at repairing sunglasses those have
broken a lot of em so I mean some of
them are beyond repair but these ones
that be fixed or something but yeah good
pair of sunglasses indoor/outdoor always
nice all those are my top 10 essentials
thank you for watching you know if you
feel like it now you can take up various
hobbies like drawing I'm able you know
whack a Bluetooth speaker in your bag
just to have a bit of vibe but there you
are as a mine